[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you really want it in the ring i
gonna send a contract out knock his
contacts out you will feel mice trying
to take a bite but ain't no competition
in the ring decipher because i'm
spitting financial swing of fire talking
pickled peppers make them pay the piper
cause i might go look like a rude
discussion and deflate your chest like a
food production you be talking like you
want a new concussion to do the custom
attitude adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve haven't
sipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
capping you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got hands on bread for the
tension i'ma leave him read you could
dance to redemption
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening
[Music]
[Music]
haters in love with the comeback salt if
you really want it in the ring i gonna
send the contract out knock his contacts
out you will feel mice trying to take a
viper ain't no competition in the ring
of cypher cause i'm spitting finally
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make em pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a fool production you be
talking like you want a new concussion
center due to custom attitude
adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve having
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you were phony homie now you owe
me action have him sinking tony tony
tony braxton and they all want to talk
for attention but the fame only lasts
for an instant momma got hands so i'm
ready for the tension i'ma leave him red
you could dance to redemption
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome
presents the featured event of the
evening
as tonight
[Music]
presented boxing
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting financial
swinging fire talking pickled peppers
make em pay the piper cause i might go
look like a rude discussion and deflate
your chest like a food production you be
talking like you want a new concussion
center due to custom attitude
adjustments
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sound which i will serve haven't
sipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
capping you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant mama got hands so i'm ready for
the picture i'ma leave him red you can
dance to redemption
[Music]
you got me right there there you go
there you go
you got me
all right so let's do that again welcome
to king wrinkle
yeah yeah i gotta get used to it baby um
thank you for joining me again
for another combat talk with the king
blessings
everybody that's joining the
professional family we gonna have some
fun right now
there we go there we go all right who we
got in the building we got down
this is my
yo i'm gonna tell y'all right now if
y'all if y'all looking for somebody
to to spit them bars or if we got any
producers in here we got anybody signing
any a rs and that track that you heard
right there that's from my man dallas
the man he's up in the chat right now
he's right in there yo i'm telling you
yo will y'all see k oh yeah i see kos
kos is coming
he's my go-to guy always will be and
always is
uh the beats is by a drum star beats so
if you love those beats fantastic if
y'all like the graphic work i tell you
all the credits is due in the beginning
graphic god that's the guy
on god in them man he's the god
so right now what we see what i'm seeing
right now i see
i see george cambodia getting stretched
out right now he's laying down
and they're stretching them out um
giving a massage
yo let's let's get into it though let's
get into it
on on god yo who y'all got tonight who
you got tonight this is a good one this
is a good one this is a real good one
this is a bomb burner
so so so talk to me i want to know who
y'all got y'all got cam bosses put one
in the chat if you got cam bosses if if
you got devin haney put two in the chat
then we're gonna get it to
if we think it's gonna be a knockout or
we're gonna think it's gonna be a
decision but what we think is gonna be
i got i got so i got some stuff
and you know
okay we got haney haney haney
haney
haney by unanimous decision haney
oh everybody in here haney hard pause
dudes in here hard on haney huh pause
the tcl leaked the results they kept the
cambosis by six round ko
[Music]
okay see mack you oh
okay hustle and motivate oh you're going
with cambosis
oh this is good what's up espy what's
good baby
all right all right
okay so
y'all okay this is a couple a couple of
things with this fight that's a little
bit controversial right
your boy um
devin haney pops was denied access to to
um australia
because of uh old felony that he had
they acted like he going to australia to
commit crimes
so they had him out for a minute but
then they let him you know show up and
and get there for his son at the last
minute you know um anything to disrupt
the mentality of the fighter oh
now i would say who this is
big uh butter that i'm putting on
but i'm not because they don't sponsor
me but if if you're watching and you
want me to form here
i mean well you want to sponsor me and
you want me to you know put that up i'll
let you know but yeah yeah
um
so they didn't let us pops over there
right
and
now his pops is dead
it can disrupt a fighter in his head
his cut man got detained in australia
or some other stuff that's another thing
that can disrupt the young fighter his
brain ain't there his family's not there
his cut man's not there what if i could
cut tonight you know those things start
playing in your head
the bigger thing is cambodians missed
weight
the first time they got on the scale
um
that's deep
you're a champion
what's going on javier
you're a champion
and you miss weight
hmm
but he he they gave him the five hours
to make the weight and he went back and
he made the weight now he tried to say
that he was playing mind games with
devon
can't fool me son
you you
i i believe he trained i really believe
he trained well but he's he's
getting a different level of celebrity
and we talk about cambodia's here right
he has a different level of celebrity
right now because he's in australia he's
going back like he said he's been on a
roll for five years he hasn't fought in
his home for five years he's been out
doing everything he got teo femo he got
the belts he got all the belts and stuff
for one piece and that's the piece devin
haney has
and
are the people there giving them too
much love what's going on right so the
thought process for me
is the dude is living high in the hog
like he probably felt that he made it
i hope not i hope he always feels like
uh this
like this young lions look nipping at
his feet
because haney coming from
y'all remember haney was trained
by floyd mayweather pops
and floyd put in some work with him
early on too so that's why he knows
distance and stuff let me see cambodia
show me heart when he fought to your
female that's right he seemed like he
did he showed me first of all
going into that fight i told wifey right
then i was like i think this campus dude
is gonna pull it off and she was like
nah i'm like yo i'm telling you oh god
i think he's gonna pull it off because
he had this energy about him
and boy oh boy
yeah yeah chris yeah mind games is for
real
uh
your boy was playing these mind games
with him
let me see
but he was in our house
yes yes yes that's what's going on
we got 27 watching yeah yeah yeah let's
just get it popping let's let's yo you
know what's crazy to me what i don't i
don't understand
like okay so you see everybody that's
here right now right and i'm pretty sure
that y'all subscribed right
share it out i said as soon as we get to
15 000 subscribers
that i'm gonna give away another console
right we and and it's gonna be
whatever console you want i don't care
playstation uh xbox uh um
a switch uh oled whatever it is uh we're
working on that
this sp gave him two hours yeah they
gave him yeah they gave him two hours i
think it was five but it's two hours i
could be wrong
yeah hit that like button i mean we got
30 watching now and you know i'm the
best in the game to give you the blow by
blow pause
yo
today i got so many statues in
today i got uh
i got magneto apocalypse and sabertooth
in
and um i gotta put all that stuff
together so
uh stay tuned for kos coming soon we
we're about to have that happen and i
just you know i had to paint the house
and all this other stuff you know
so we're gonna get that going all right
so
wow that place that arena looks nice
this is the first time i'm seeing the
arena i wanted to do a drink that's uh
from australia and they got some drink
called the white lady
and you had to mix wine and some other
stuff and then they had a lot of
martinis i had martinis last week on
vacation um
i
had this one martini from this mexican
place they gave the best martinis i've
ever tasted my life people i'm gonna
tell you right now
one martini you're done son so you know
my behind i'm sitting there i'm like
give me two of them joints i have one
martini then i had the the the mango
martini
buddy i had to sit there for a minute
before we got back
it's crackling a little bit again
damn we just went over this hold on let
me hear it
it's not a stare down contest you're
right
okay
yeah okay so addict showed me something
let me let me try to work that out
can you have half cambodians can i hope
you enjoy your vacation yeah rich boy
he said sixth round
tank was gonna do it in a six hour i
told you yeah yeah he got it done tank
did get it done let me see let me go
has not risen at all let me see
what to do
was it uh let me take out this media
am i still crackling
if i'm still crackling put a one in the
chat
a better fighter
it's something that addict did it's not
type of thing
it's um
work with me with it
let me take away the kings
let me see
how that sounds
does that sound better
especially
tim i want to ask you about the status
the title
that should be put on georgetown here's
the bottom line he said you also said
yes better now yo
all right so
what happened was what happened was
right
when i logged in
um being you know i wasn't here for a
whole week or whatever
you have your updates
what's your bad last weekend man
yeah yo
i'm telling you i watched that fight
and
it wasn't me
or did okay
did i get rolly rounds just because
rolly did better than i expected
or
was it the fact that
um rowley was actually doing work
mixed berry frozen daiquiri malibu and
rum that's what's up
that's what's up
i got um
special mix uh
you already know sir rock on deck yo
diddy shout out to your boy um
and
a little bit of orange juice but i got i
got a secret i got a secret juice that
i'm mixing it
and
the juice actually it's i can't i can't
i can't say anything about him if y'all
could tell by the can right
i hope you could tell by the can
you hope you can tell what again i i
can't say it because it's a direct
competitor to who sponsors my boys so i
can't say their name
he's working man he just got caught up
with
a hell of a lot yeah
yo
tell me he didn't it didn't look like i
mean tank tank has power and remember
that was just an arm punch that tank hit
him with right
tell me tank
didn't look like floyd when floyd caught
um and just i mean i'm not talking about
exactly you know floyd's posture because
they have totally different posture tank
looks more when he boxes he looks more
like mike tyson than me when he boxes in
his posture right but tell me he didn't
look like floyd remember when floyd uh
caught ricky hatton coming in with that
left hook that chef left hook and ricky
had had hit the turnbuckle when he fell
back out
tell me he didn't look like that
like he baited him in he baited him in
he baited him in and then he hit him
with their left
and it was sweet it was sweet oh my god
um
and i didn't and he didn't hit rolly it
was just rolly's momentum rolly was
given so much of his power going forward
that he got he just got caught with it
was a dead the catch
um
and then it is
i looked and i was like okay
if it was something that he saw coming
rolly could have took the punch
rolly was completely defenseless when he
got hit with that shot
so
he got up but he wasn't he wasn't right
man he wasn't right and i think it was a
good stoppage
because you know i was saying like if
they let them go you can ruin a fighter
i was watching
fighters being ruined by certain things
and you let them keep going and get
ruined like meldrick taylor when he got
ruined from
chavez julius caesar chavez jr i mean
lulu sees the shop that's not junior oh
please
um
that fighter got ruined later on from a
knockout and i noticed a complete
different thing that went you know 12
rounds
and
you know that happened but
i just really wanted rolly either to get
knocked out like that and don't take a
beating because i think that's good for
the fighter right that he just got
knocked out like that and he didn't take
a beating right
let me see be right back about to
take a look at it again that's what's up
take yeah but
he tank saw it
he didn't just throw it out there
oh welcome to bronze jay panera what's
going on
yo it's he he sort of shot if you look
at it tank saw the shot because tank was
baiting i mean fainted him a couple of
times but rolly was throwing a nice you
know um
mid shots because he knows tank likes to
dip into shots so he's trying to catch
tank with those shots that he dips into
i i think rolly gave a good account of
himself but we also saw a different
wrinkle to take because like tank was
saying
he said he felt this power
tank kept it real
a hundred percent
that he felt rowley's power pause
and he said you know what i'm gonna lay
off him before i just dig into the fight
and we all know a fight starts after the
fifth round really be honest with you
guys um in any professional fight it
really starts after the fifth round
that's when you already acclimated to
the person you already know the
tendencies you already know what they're
gonna lean into and what you what you're
gonna see from them
other than hanero is good you
unknown unknown is this true cambodia's
to win by round five or is it cap
it didn't even happen yet
it didn't even happen yet
uh chris beezy he said he's still strong
yeah he
he said he was still strong
you know so
that's a hard one man pulse
i honestly think that um
he needed two more fights he needed two
more fights but you can't take no shade
away from tank you know tank got to
fight these young dudes like
shakur
haney if haney uh gets out of here with
this
you know i'm gonna keep it a buck with
you you know usually i like to drag it
out right before they're about to go out
i'm gonna keep it a buck with you
this fight here scares the hell out of
me
all right because
when earl spence went over to england
and he took the belt uh from um this guy
he
he he faced some adversity in that fight
we're not gonna act like you know um
earl didn't face no adversity in a fight
he faced some adversity in that fight
right but he got it by knockout if it
went to a decision what would we have
saw right
we
know
all the shenanigans that went on with
how the government
and somebody else that was in charge
tried to keep haney's camp out of
certain things right
who's it say that something don't go
fishy with the cards
and we haven't seen haney
uh be that knockout artist that can get
a dude out of there especially a dude
like cam bosses because we don't front
man tio femo hit this dude with some
hell of a shots and cam bosses got up
right so
this is a conundrum here because don't
don't front guys don't don't i don't
want nobody sitting here captain talking
about they know that cambosis is that
dude and we i've been following his
whole career and i know no
i didn't know anything about cambosis
until he was fighting to your female and
then the fight got delayed remember and
it was supposed to be on trilla and it
was first of all supposed to be your top
rank and then top rank there wanted that
was supposed to be on trilla then trilla
you know fell out with it then it found
itself someplace or whatever the hell
but the fight happened
and
then you sort of measure the man right
loma let me see see he's looking strong
i live in australia early
it's live early in australia kel brooke
cambo has heart yeah
flash in the pan pacquiao and jeff phone
fight okay yo chris
that pacquiao
and jeff horn fight
that's that's that's exactly what i'm
talking about
we saw pacquiao beat jeff horn right
no slight to jeff horn
jeff horn went in and he made it dirty
he made it nasty but
don't we expect cambosis to do the same
thing devin hayme is a slick boxer
if if the judges ain't looking for that
or don't score that you know you
can he lose out
i want to know
if devin haney
can box off the front foot not the back
foot
box off the front foot
i know he can control distance but can
he close the show can he get him in
trouble because remember
he just finished fighting and
linares and lanares caught him with a
little
okie doke dead you understand
you know linares had him a little bit of
on queer street
and lenoris don't hit like cambodia's
campos got them dynamites in them sticks
because nobody here expected cambosis to
drop teo fema in the first round
tio femo didn't even expect that to femo
got up looking around like like the ref
kicked them in the back of the head
right so
this is a tough one man you want the
young kid to go out there you want to
hey yeah usa
you know pride and all that other stuff
but
this is this is this if if this has been
the best 50 50 split on a fight that
i've seen in a long time
come on
he said you want to see haney push cam
booster back yeah i do
yeah i do
i want to see him
i'm going to see him walk him down
i want um
who's your money going on champ
i'm wondering
if they try to rob haney
and do it you know what
this is true
um let me see rich boy what you got here
guy haney winning but i'm concerned
about
his chin holding up that's everybody's
concern with haney
that's yo
i've everybody that i talk to
every time that i watch stuff i mean the
consensus is you know bags don't hit
back you know he looked good on the bags
all his fights he looks decent but he he
everybody says oh he has pillow fists
right
you have pedraza right now that's
getting ready to fight maloney
um
no no no no that was the earlier fight
or pedraza versus maloney so i think
maloney is coming up next getting ready
fight i didn't really look at the
undercard to be honest with you to see
who was on the undercard because all i
cared about was this fight
undisputed or lightweight
excuse me undisputed at lightweight
you know they rowdy out there i love
that i love that sense of pride you know
like the garden when the garden is
really rocking that sense of pride
hailing anyone i'm not mentioning
anything cambodia throws will cause the
fans yo that is so true man he reminds
me of ruiz i want to see him in deep
i can't post it
um
anything that he does the crowd is going
to go crazy
the crowd is going to go absolutely
insane
haney has to remove the crowd from the
factory can he do so i don't think
a slick boxer
that boxes off the back foot can do so
and he's very very cautious very
cautious right so what what are we gonna
see here or we're gonna see
i i'm happy that his father's there
because i know his father's gonna tell
him yo step it up lean into it give him
some body shots
and
i i think he can do it i think he can do
it yo who saw zab judah pops dead zab
judo pops is there working to mix with
him and we already know zab do the pops
i mean he's uh what was he uh kickboxing
champion
zap judah pops got some hands you know
you know shout out to brooklyn brooklyn
stand up that's what's up 108 dragons
what's good baby
um
i think
i think
this is going to be a good one for as
long as it lasts
haney is going to have to risk going to
the body to take some of that the power
the punching power away from cambosis
cambosis
reminds me like of a honey badger
you know and his punches comes quick his
defense is not all the way there he has
holes in his defense but he's like that
that honey badge he's going to stay on
top of you he's going to you know try to
just you know claw it out
he's very scrappy
very diligent in his work
um and very forceful
um
teo fimo is a strong
lightweight a big strong lightweight for
his size a big strong lightweight for
him to drop that big strong lightweight
like that
and remember lomo
didn't drop tia fema
and he was pushing lomo back
um
i don't i don't know man this is this is
a hard one and pause and for everybody
here that's that's that's going for
cambosis
you might not be wrong
you might not be wrong at the end of the
night it might be something spectacular
let me see let me see let me see
we saw haney got hurt versus norris yes
that's true
thoughts on robin garcia training
aj
huh
i didn't know that
i wouldn't want robert garcia training
aj
um
you know
who i would i would love
for
george foreman
or linux lewis
to train aj
because aj's at a point right now in his
career where
aj is a complete fighter right
no new trainer is going to come in and
teach him anything different very
off-topic king but did you listen to
uh
griselda
do i do do i listen to griselda yeah
listen to grizzler
of course
i'm from new york what are you crazy
um
i i just i think
you have to have a heavy weight
to show him
you know he has to learn the cronk style
right the kronk style of boxing and the
cronk style emmanuel emmanuel stewart is
no longer with a
rest in peace
uh aj needs to learn
to box tall
long
because he has a bad [ __ ] lennox had a
bad chin
george foreman
he had a decent chin
but he had uh stamina problems early on
he needs to aj needs to learn
how to protect himself and
the way he fights sometimes he fights
too in close
and he gives up his height he has to
learn not to do that remember lennox
used to do that early on in his career
and after he got knocked out um emanuel
stewart
trained him to be an unstoppable monster
he was a very unstoppable monster
what up uh you didn't mean any any you
didn't miss anything vlog no
let me see let me see i agree ag problem
is mental
it's it's mental but it's also
boxing
you know
he boxing with us
who said got hands for days
don't act like black like the borrowers
has been claiming buffalo you'll be
stupid
i wouldn't have sugar he'll train aj but
fury got him
i said i will have no fury's not
fighting no more
fury's retired
all right so um fury fury gave up his
belt he retired and he wants um
deontay wilder
and uh to fight for his uh his vacant
belt so fury's not fighting him fury's
done
there's no need for him to fight
the the
the dude that can actually
beat fury
couldn't beat fury
he was never getting an aj fight they
would have never put him in there with
aj he would ate aj alive
um so that fight was never going to
happen
no he retired
so yeah sugar hill can definitely uh
train aj and i think i think aj should
look to sugar hill to train him to teach
him
you know not not all the cheating ways
just you know teach him how to fight
tolerant i think aj has at least four or
five more more fights left to be honest
with you
you know um
brutal knockouts um
he needs
at least four or five more fights and
then you know he's done because who
who's he gonna fight we all really want
them to fight deontay wilder right we
all want to see that fight we don't want
it to be like ridicule and lennox lewis
for that fight to have always been there
and never happened right that that fight
to oh it's a wonderful fight that could
happen but these two individuals never
got it together riddick both throwing
the belt in the garbage and you know
linux lewis willing to fight but it i
always felt that that
length on riddick beau i think
rick bowe was you know didn't want lenny
smalls to fight
means ottawa lost two fury
was the ufc heavyweight champ
uh
aj not fighting wilder that's the only
fight for aj to take
it doesn't matter if aj if wilder
destroys aj it really doesn't matter at
all
listen both of them got losses right
they're not the pristine little uh
packages that we had before that oh
they did they they held them
that's what happens when fights aren't
made that's why spence and crawford has
to be made right before one of them take
a l right
uh
so i truly expect
aj to just it's the big money grab it's
the only big fight money grab for aj
it's the only big money fight for for
wilder wilder has to get a fight get a
belt and get a knockout aj just has to
get a fight and win it's the only money
fight for either one of them and i
honestly believe that whoever wins
retires like they both retire be honest
with you win lose a draw i think both of
them just retire because they're not
i
i think something was
was taken out of wilder
in that fury trilogy i think
he lost the measure of something because
he had a true belief in himself and i
think he started to self-doubt right so
self-doubt
took a little something away aj always
had self-doubt with his chin and ruiz
taught him what his chin really is about
so
i i honestly think those two just need
to fight and give us what we want to get
it over with
oh simply facts thank you for
is that canadian i want 1.49 thank you
my brother thank you that's what's up i
appreciate that
i'm talking about aj hart
king
yeah
aj hart
i don't know man i don't know who aj
hart is tell me who aj is
they're saying spins and crawford will
possibly be in october it's supposed to
be in october um actually they was
trying to do it on the anniversary of
sugar ray leonard versus tommy hearns
and
had
you know
i don't want to put all the blame on
crawford because
you know everybody knows i like spence
right so there's nothing about that is
you know and everybody knows going into
that fight i pick spitz um but
i don't want to put the blame on
crawford and and holding this up
because
he want to get the most out of his money
right now he's his own
boss now right so he wants to get the
most out of it going into this right so
spence doesn't care
the guy looked down deaf already so he
signed the contract let's go put that
out there i don't care what's what
whatever it is my ems is always right
i'm good i just want to get this done
all right um derek james
has got them dudes the guys that he
trains
on a mentality of becoming undisputed
regardless to what
so
nah i honestly think you know that
holdup is dead but
aj needs to fight wilder
let me see
oh he says his heart beating into the
fight
aj god is kevin hart's brother
yo i'm
done
yo there's something wrong with y'all
and you spell heart that way i ain't
think he was talking
yo
yo
you yo you're ridiculous you're
ridiculous yeah in september
that's that's what i thought chris i
thought the fight would be in september
on the anniversary
of uh sugar ray leonard versus um
hearns
and
oh man
that would be great too
that's the undisputed
y'all don't know how rare this is this
this year boxing right this year of
boxing pay-per-views has been at an
all-time high fights every weekend and
not no crappy fights these have been
banger after banger after banger
um
do we have a good year of boxing and and
to culminate at the end of the year
uh
do we get um oh well we got canelo
fighting triple g he don't want none of
that bavar smoke he's like no i'm gonna
leave bavaro especially with valsa
if bavar said
i'll go down there and fight you at your
weight class for all your belts i'll
i'll do that
canelo's excuse you
oh oh no no no i i had only wanted to
challenge you for your stuff all my
stuff no no we will not be fighting for
my stuff sir you have a blessed night
good night
you know bevar was like nah i'll go down
i'll fight you at your weight for your
belts how about that how about we good
and he's like no we are not good sir i
will fight triple g triple g triple g is
there a triple g in the build yes thank
you so please sign the contract
yes undisputed yes
suppose
be deaf
without a seat belt yeah man
canelo's a joke i i don't
no one want to see triple g3 nobody want
to see that but
it's in the best interest of canelo
because what you're gonna have him go
you're gonna have canelo go fight
benavidez
you're gonna have canelo go fight um
uh jamal
you
what canelo doesn't have that lateral
movement that he normally has
anymore do y'all see that the little um
bands that he used on his knee that's to
keep his his his knee in place you know
because he could have little tears here
and there acls or whatever
small meniscus tears or whatever and
then he has uh he'd be having them on
his shoulders when he's training
now anytime you put those on that's
because your arms are getting tired or
you have little things here and there
little nicks and stuff you're trying to
get yourself out of training with no
problems
i'm telling you
that this
he's getting older he's been in a lot of
wars
fight triple g
um get that belt
and you're looking at probably two more
fights down the line if he fights david
benavidez
he has a shot and catching benavidez but
benavidez has a shot and beating the
brakes off for him something terrible
and then if he fights charlo i don't
give him a shot in hell when beating
charlo
not one in hell
so canelo is on the path and his team is
uh is is doing well with him you know
remember he's later on his career he had
a lot of fights he
it's not like he has
a little bit of fights and he has uh
something left to give nah he he he's
done a lot of fights and a lot of times
you know
that can wear and tear on a fighter so
there's a lot of injuries we got 44 in
here we only got 33 likes let's get
those like buttons up
no one wants benavidez because benavidez
doesn't offer money
all right so
right now um
we have maloney in the ring
with
uh
[Music]
plaquette
never seen either one of these two
fighters
um
the blanket is from the philippines
and maloney is australian
see that's a lot of times these
governments
you put your your fighters in that
you've never seen on the card and that
and that's cool
um but this this is early on top rank
does this a lot top rank does a lot of
weird under cards that don't give you
value for your money and you'll be
pissed off the fact that triple g and
canelo was on the back burner is nuts
yeah that's crazy
let me see i think canelo fight is going
to be
he's going to fight triple g will be his
last which we triple g last fight
probably so benavidez might
might be canelo's final fight meanwhile
he'll probably face charlo and andre
are you crazy
first of all he's never gonna fight
andrade
canelo would never fight andre i don't
care what you say first of all andrade
nobody wants to fight andrade he's the
highest risk with the least amount of
money that you're going to get in return
nobody wants to fight him that why do
you think he hasn't been in there with
charlo why do you think i mean benavidez
might fight them
benavidez has the most to gain from
fighting andrade so if we can get
andrade versus benavidez i mean that
that's a dynamic fight within itself two
highly
uh avoided fighters that don't bring too
much to the table as far as finances
that can build off of each other if they
can get something going and can get a
trilogy or something like that popping
and get their names going yeah that can
work that can actually work but um as
far as charla won't fight uh uh
whatchamacallit he might fight better
media's because he's going up if jamal
might fight benavidez because jamal is
going up and jamal is going up and after
um spence
and
crawford
lose his draw spence is going up after
jamal's belts that he leaves so i mean
jamel's doubts that he leaves
let me see benavidez is the boogeyman
right hell yeah benavidez is the
boogeyman maloney got
destroyed by
now oh for real
canelo andrade is a horrible fighter
that's he's a horrible fighter because
he doesn't he doesn't follow format
he doesn't give you value for your money
and it's a high possibility he gonna
beat you behind right so yeah he's a
horrible fighter for canelo hell yeah
it makes no sense that's why he's
screaming you want payday you want paid
it of course he want to pay day off for
you
of course he wants to pay the offer but
he had those belts and he and canelo did
everything to sidestep individuals to go
get different belts
and that's how he got david benavida's
belt david benavidez didn't make weight
they stripped him of the belt what does
canelo do fight for his vacant belt come
on man then that [ __ ] had never
hard
happened
oh yeah i like
i'm going to watch cool boy stuff yeah
i'm not going to watch him um
watch him i think he's he's fighting
tonight right cool boy stuff is fighting
tonight right all the stuff i catch um
later on like i'll be up
right before iop i stay up all night
after this
so
i'll be up all night
shout out to zorka i told zalka because
me and zaka was texting in the
background because i was showing him
some statues and some statues that i
have for sale because um you know i'm
mainly into xm studio and i have some
sideshow statues and he's trying to get
into the statue game so i had some
statues there and i was like i got them
you know i can let them go for a good
price for you um i said but i gotta go
take a nap i gotta go to bed he's like
how are you going to bed so early for us
i gotta i got a show tonight um beyond
and then i'll be up all damn night
um
yo yeah i know he's fighting now i'm i
can't watch it now because i paid for
this you know i i paid for this
so
they should have had cool boy fighting
here you know but no
no they want to split you all over the
place
the cool boy about the fight now
yo listen man if y'all man
let me let me let me just jump over real
quick i love cool boy too man i ain't
gonna lie no cat let me see let me see
as i was watching um
haney versus um
i mean not haney um
this dude uh tank versus this guy
earlier
no
hold on
that's a pbc
you talking about on showtime right now
i got two screens i got actually i got
three screens i got this screen here i
got that screen there and i got this
screen over here i got three screens but
one i gotta control the show two i gotta
talk to y'all in the chat and three i
can watch cool boy right now so alright
so check it out
since since this is what y'all get y'all
asking for we gonna do the cool boy
thing right now because i love cool boy
stuff i'm not gonna lie i love how his
style is
yo you know what he looks like what's
that rapper out of harlem
um
what's that rapper nas uh
he said i need four yo mac i only have
40 people watching how the hell i'm
gonna afford four streams mac really
really max stop playing
it's not like i get super super chats
and stuff like that now but yo after yo
oh yo you're gonna be crazy dope yeah i
got i got the calling machine right i
got the calling machine i got the call
yeah he looked he looked like davies
right
yes yo he definitely looked like davies
yo all right so i got the calling
machine shout out to solve and
everything everything got sent to me i
got the calling machine but remember
combat talk is not supposed to be down
here combat talk is supposed to be
upstairs in my other statue room well
this is the media room right this is not
the red room and sometimes when you'll
see pictures you saw pictures today on
twitter i was in the red room they're
gonna see
uh videos
with me upstairs inside the other statue
room and
that this is a more chilled out
environment yo y'all get a chance to see
the big screen tv so i'm gonna have like
off
decide you can see the fight a little
bit you know type of stuff and it's
gonna be calling um my whole thing is
having you guys call in
uh i throw her mark marky man you you
kind of messed me up i was like what
abner morris
that guy ran the hell away from tanks
said yeah my eyeball hurt i'm out
[Music]
i i really can't stand
uh showtime's uh commentating
not at all but um
all right so listen we kind of switched
some gas because top ranks under cars be
draga all right by suda
trash if you will um we switched over to
showtime pbc
now pvc definitely put put them cards on
for them boys right so we're going to
talk about we're going to watch cool boy
stuff comes up into the ring right now
and then we're going to switch gears and
run back right over to haney versus um
cambosis
all right danny roman yo i gotta i got
my brother see i got a tattoo on my hand
i know my mama y'all can't see my black
you can see just the silhouette of it
i'm so black right
um
shout out to my blackness hey
uh
my
it's it's seven of us that got this
tattoo
and one of my brother's name is uh
danny roman so when they was like danny
roman's fighting i'm like what the hell
but nah that's not my boy
oh my god they got bladder impaler
[Music]
talking to men
danny is pretty decent um cool boy this
is this is a nice uh fight for cool boy
steph
um to see exactly what he's uh
what he's gonna bring to the table
that's right hit that like button share
that out we got 47 we got 37 likes let's
share that out um
listen
i'm going to give you the best play by
play ain't nobody going to give you play
by play like me blow by blow pause
all right so i'm telling you right now
this is definitely what it's going to be
we here
oh this looks good i love how pvc and
showtime
uh presentation is their presentation is
really good you know top rank
has nice cameras
but
pvc and showtime
uh
they have like the cinematic quality to
it and i guess it's because showtime
does movies and everything like that uh
that they they bring that cynic
cinematic quality to their fights it
really looks really good this really
looked like some rocky movie stuff
i see guru in the back holding it let me
see hold on
let me see
i think this is going to be bad for
canelo either way if he wins no one
cares most people will simply chalk it
up to cheap triple b
all right
what type of bounce-back fight you want
canelo to have
who you want him to to to do you want
him to get his behind with by duvall and
go
fight
jamal
or
get no money and go fight andrade
or get no money and go fight better
vetoes
or get triple g out of all three of
those dudes
pays him the most money
with the least risk
hello
why wouldn't he like
why wouldn't he
he always kept that in his pocket man
yeah rest in peace hbo boxing hbo boxing
put on some hell of a shows back in the
days shout out to larry merchant and
them teams
man that was it hey go cool boy
you got a rapper coming out with them
yeah yeah that's what they do
yeah cool boy outside
young dave young davies in the face
i tried to promote the show oh thank you
man i do appreciate you promoting the
show man nothing be hbo please and hell
yeah
listen this i i appreciate everybody and
anything you know share it out whatever
i'm just i know i'm gonna watch the
fights right and i said
a lot of times i do combat talk in the
beginning of iop shows right
and
sometimes y'all be up at night too
so why not hang out we watch fights and
talk fights
who cares
right let's do that
i think that's dope but i also wanted to
be calling
so you dudes can call in and
they can hear you
she see the conversation that you having
in the chat
i want you to have a conversation with
me on the phone
so you call them bing bing ah we we chop
it up for real so you can really get
your bars off instead of just sitting
there typing you drink hey okay man you
know and you know how we don't curse
anyway so you know keep it cool keep it
clean and we talk fights
that's what i want to bring
i want to bring that element to it that
like how everybody used to hang out on
saturdays or whatever with their friends
on friday nights go watch the fights get
some chips talk have a good
time
so we got cool boy in the ring right now
danny roman is in the ring right now
and uh yeah yeah this is what's up
and i can't wait for him to get some
more bread i'm not really feeling the
outfit i'm not really feeling the outfit
you know
you know something you know at the pvc
they could have hooked him up you know
got him a nice little uh
better outfit you know
let me see combat talk it's a brilliant
idea i look forward to saturdays thank
you i appreciate that man
i really do i really do
cool boy 27 years old danny roman 32
5 6 versus five five danny roman five
five
they both came in on weight and a cool
boy
is uh has a little bit of an arm reached
70 and a half versus 67 and a half on um
danny roman
so
we know that uh roman is going to
box in i hate saying that traditional
mexican style and boxing and cool boy is
going to box in traditional american
style
um
boxing what's american style boxing
what's mexican style boxing right
um
we all know what the code word is for so
we're gonna say uh you know cool boy is
gonna box he's a boxer puncher
and we're going to say that uh danny is
a
a fighter slugger right
alas caesar chavez
not saying that mexicans developed that
style or perfected that style just
saying that there's a certain style of
boxing that mexicans uh do train in and
i love it it's an exciting style
so
uh
and boxing punching is is a fantastic
style for me too especially if you got
some pop
let me see let me see damn i was hoping
that maloney fight will last longer
combat talk a little bit mc
you've seen your work brother
we seen your work brother you're a potty
mouth
and a true new york this is true this is
true sir
do you watch cool boy versus figaro yes
i did
let me see
okay okay
vladimir is uh introducing them
i always say he look like a vampire
here we go here we go
yo
i i know this is a stupid question
who do y'all got in this fight do you
got danny or do you got cool boy
i know that's a stupid question
but again i mean
because i i don't think al haymon and
the pvc puts uh cool boy in in a
situation where he's going to lose right
now i mean in my opinion i think that um
they they keep it cool so you know danny
roman has uh 29 wins three losses one
draw with ten knockouts that means that
he has absolutely no punching power he
lost three times already and he has a
draw all right and that's that's a good
measuring stick for cool boy as he goes
up
in uh
boxing ranks right
and
they have cool boy coming in next
very very very
this is a very good measuring stick type
of a fight stepping stone type of a
fight good fight
cool boy standing there
looking smooth looking ready to fight
you remember before where they had to
they used to make them shave their beds
off so he's a 20-year-old
with eight knockouts
that's another thing uh he's just a pure
boxer
right that means that uh he doesn't go
for
uh
i yo
you are out of control max
he said
go away man cut it out
not today
he doing it for the jokes
wow
that front row looked crazy
if you saw the front row that was dead
for cool boy
that front row looked crazy
please say that you're watching that
please say that you saw that front row
hallelujah holla back
that's what i'm talking about
oh somebody got to get them and then in
that gym and tighten up that they they
both looking loose looking loose looking
loose
nah somebody gotta you know give him
some of that uh
some of that stuff that canelo eating
so some of that stuff that they gave um
rolly
you said joshua too who you got i don't
think that fight happens
i don't think that fight happens at all
you say joshua too i don't think that
fight happens
i think um while they come back get that
belt and i think uh
they make that fight as quickly as
possible
aj versus wilder as quickly as possible
he said mexican meat pulse panero come
on
i mean primo come on
all right so this looks like it's going
to go a complete 12 rounds
[Music]
you know cool boy is nice
i love how cool boy
you know bounces off the front foot so
right now in the center of the ring cool
boys throwing a jab oh danny comes in in
the boxing style not a pure mexican
style rushing forward no they're both
two boxes
and they're in the center of the ring
fainting jabs uh and uh throwing right
hands they're both in the orthodox style
so you have a cool boy with the orange
gloves and
um roman with the gray gloves
both everlast i believe no one has reyes
one has uh everlast
all right so they're just exchanging
jabs in the center of the ring
um
both of them are boxing off the front
foot
uh cool boy bounces back in and out he
darts in and out
and danny goes uh side to side so danny
has a little bit more lateral movement
while cool boy has a lot more uh
circular in and out movement
all right so right now
you have uh danny that's uh pressing the
attack
uh to be honest with you wow uh
cool boy is
throwing a little bit of jabs here and
there he tried to do overhand right cool
boy is backing up mostly
while danny is jabbing to cool boy's
chest
cool boy is jabbing to danny's uh
shoulder and it's just a jab fest right
now guys
oh all right so kubo tried to throw one
two danny throws a one-two right back
and they go right back to the center of
the ring and it's just a jab fest
again
like i said
they both jabbed each other at the same
time and both
stepped back
uh danny seems to me to be winning the
round cool boy is throwing more jabs
he's starting to land more jabs but
danny is uh taking more control of the
ring
while cool boys show a more general ship
of the ring ring generalship
all right
uh so they're back in the center ring
they haven't really left the center ring
to be honest with you just a little bit
here and there back and forth
um
jabs
danny is still pressing
while cool boy is throwing triple jabs
um
nothing too much is happening danny
tries an overhand right
cool boy hops back and danny tries our
inside uppercut cool boy hops back right
hand cool boy catches him with a left
foot coming in check left hook
and
all right cool boy and danny again
jabs nothing too much right now
but you can say um
if anything i i will give danny this
first round round is almost over because
uh danny pressed more of the attack and
cool boy was more on the back foot
pushing up against the ropes to be
honest with you so
me personally uh that first round was
more of a fill out round but do we give
cool boy that round no i can't give cool
boy that round i gotta go with danny on
that
yeah if it freezes for me too that's
when they send that bullet through so if
you didn't pay for it
bye
yeah it froze for me too really quickly
and then
it went straight though
that's how um
showtime dude that's why hbo has beaten
him for a long time
let me go right back real quick
check and see if that fight is over with
get right back to it
we are not missing this hanging fight
that's hell to the no no no
no no no hell to the no no no
all right so it's not time yet they
still talking
they having uh dinner time
all right so
it's back to the same action uh danny's
pressing a little bit more and cool boy
he has cool boy up against the ropes
um
and cool boys a little bit slick with
his shoulders moving from side to side
cool boy throwing jabs
danny goes to the body cool boy has a
nice check left hook
on danny coming in nice jab nice long
jab
a cool boy does and
nice movements
he steps back and he moves his his
footwork is really good then he goes to
the body
and he he gets cool boy up against the
ropes they have to teach danny how to
cut off the ring a little bit better but
um
right now okay so
cool boy tried a one two it was blocked
and then he uh counted with a left jab
so boom oh
left to the to the body from danny left
to the head
same hand
all right cool boy tries to overhand
right
okay cool boy does a nice jab
nice jab
danny again doubles up his jab and he's
throws a right hand catches cool boy
and he's putting a little bit more work
than cool boy
the cool boy jab is just uh unrelenting
he keeps the jab he keeps that stick out
there but he keeps giving up grounds
danny keeps pressing cool boys back is
up against the rope danny catches them
with a short left hook inside cool boy
grabs
referee breaks them up they go right
back to the action
all right so
cool boys back to jabbing
all right
danny takes uh catches them with a nice
left hook tries to catch him with the
overhand right he almost did then he
catches them to the body
body does a lot of body work cool boy's
trying to hold then he's throwing body
work
cool boy goes back to the jab
back to the jab in the center of the
ring danny does
cool boy tries to sneak in a 1-2 danny
counters with a 1-2
uh but he's still pushing uh cool boy
back up against ropes he catches cool
boy in the body with a straight right
hand and throws another right hand
catches him to the body who would
counters off the ropes with a left hook
and they back into the center of the
ring
right now center the ring
nothing's thrown all right
danny leaps in with a left hook then
goes right back to the jab he is
pressing the attack and goes to a right
hand and goes right back and he's
ripping shots to cool boys body while
the referee breaks them up
again i give another round to danny
danny's coming here to fight
who you got king uh devin and george
and why
um i
i got i got devin right but um i'm going
to tell you right now
i'm not secure in that choice right
um conventional wisdom tells you that
it's supposed to be devin uh devin is
supposed to fight but i want to see
devin fight off the front foot and not
the back foot in this fight i want him
to go into this fight because you see
right now with cool boy cool boy is
giving up too much um
ring he's giving up too much
uh
right now
and danny's taking that that space so to
me danny's winning this fight right that
can happen with uh haney versus cambosis
it can actually be the same thing you
know so
what we want to see and what's going to
happen i'm going to give it to um
hang me i get haney by unanimous
decision but he has a cut over his eye
are you serious
oh right hand cool boy stepping up to
action round okay okay because to me
he's down two rounds right so cool boy
throws throws jabs stiff uh
jabs left hook
bouncing back
left hook check left hook
danny's trying to sell out right now
when i'm talking about selling out danny
is going in to make the fight
right
i'm a cool boy he's holding his ground
now he's boxing off the front foot this
is what i'm talking about right when you
switch from inside now he's swinging
with purpose all right the jab is very
strong the left hook is very good
very good strong jab very good left hook
good tight defense now he's not backing
up all the way and they're standing in
the center of the ring right now but uh
then he's still pressing the attack
pushing forward
good pressure forward
all right so
back to the center of the ring
uh cool boy is throwing jabs
all right this is this is a very good
technical fight just like they just said
you know
but i love the fact that uh cool boy has
um
oh straight right hand over the top from
cool boy uh danny was coming in now that
slow danny's progress down danny slowed
down a little bit but he's back to the
jab back to prussian cool boy so he
caught cool boy with a right hand he
threw two left to the body and he's
working the body every time he gets
close uh cool boy gets out of that uh
clinch and goes right back to jab
he goes into the philly crab shell and
he throws a jab with a left hook right
behind it beautiful work
beautiful work
and he tries to sneak in a straight
right hand but he's back to the jab
all right and danny uh throws his jab
pushes cool boy back
all right
danny throws two pouring left he's going
to the body
and he's throwing up because he's
letting that left hand goal danny is
throw oh straight right hand from cool
boy right down the pipe one two then
right back to the jab he tried to
uppercut inside cool boys back to the
jab
danny's standing in the middle of the
ring uh they're in the center on the
logo right now
all right and uh cool boy throws a left
hook throws a jab
he's got he has the right hand [ __ ]
ready to go and he shoots it straight
from his chest
they need to teach him to keep it out a
little bit further so he can throw it a
little bit faster
very good very good stuff
uh-huh he's doing a lot of footwork
round is almost over 13 seconds in
all right
and nice jab from cool boy right hand
over the top
and left hook coming in cool boy spins
off and walks away that's the first
round that i gave cool boy in this fight
all right so it's uh two rounds the one
cool boy is down to me cool boy lost
both rounds yes he did
can devin win if he leaves it up to the
judges
i don't know man
i think he needs to sell out
i think devon needs to go in and give
110 percent i think he needs to sell out
i think he needs to go in there with the
thought process of trying to stop ken
bosu
let me see
that lead right is such a great punch it
is such a great punch especially if you
fainted him see what cool boy was doing
was he fainted him a couple of times
into that right hand because he kept
doing the jab had him busy watching the
jab watching no jab watching the jab and
then he'd throw the right hand right
over and shoot the right hand right
through the gap
and that's exactly how you're supposed
to operate if you're a boxer puncher
right
well i think cool boy is more of a pure
boxer
to be honest with you he's not you know
i would consider roy jones a box of
puncher roy jones is the
he has the the that speed their power
same thing with sugar ray leonard boxer
puncher
all right so
they're back in the center of the ring
and i i think this goes a good six seven
rounds
to be honest with you before cool boy
starts to really heat up because cool
boy is trying to get danny
to lean more into his shots all right so
all right so cool what they jab and cool
boy's trying to throw the right over the
top then he blocks it because cool boy
is targeting danny's um
left eye
right because he has a cut over his left
eye so cool boy is targeting that left
eye
all right so they're back in the center
of the ring after that clinch
oh oh nice body shot by danny over the
hand right by cool boy it wasn't faze
stiff jab
stiff jab
by uh cool boy
all right stiff jab by cool boy
stiff jab
then he tries to come in and tries to go
for the right hand
beautiful jab
beautiful oh
cool boy is trying to
chop over the top
oh danny showing fight they're all in
the center of the ring this is high
level chess i love this this is a
beautiful round
from cool boy
cool boy is throwing a nice jab danny is
pouring with his jab trying to push cool
boy back
the one thing i don't like about cool
boy is he's back touches the ropes a
little too much for me
uh-huh
all right so yeah but nice stiff jabs as
danny keeps trying to press the attack
and he's waiting then he keeps blocking
his jab now now daddy's preoccupied he
tried to shoot him right over the top
and that missed cool boy stepped out the
way laterally
all right
they bumped the heads
but nothing uh nothing too much
all right danny leaps in with a left
hook
cool boy tries to catch him with
overhand right
and he's spinning them around danny has
lost a little bit of zip in his style oh
one two by cool boy danny legs doesn't
look too sharp right now another one two
by cool boy another stiff jab by cool
boy
all right so right now in the center of
the ring cool boy is doing his most work
right now danny does a one two uh cool
boy blocks with his shoulder straight
right hand from cool boy that was a
beautiful one he boxes so long pulse and
he extends and gets full extension on
all his shots which is really really
good
all right
nice check left hook
all right
and uh danny comes in tries to go to the
body
good round i give that round again the
cool boy
all right
shoot over here real quick
let's see what's going on with this
fight though
not gonna play around we're not playing
around with dev on
what the hell why is hula
why are they talking about hold on
this is ridiculous
how the hell they got commercials was
reality-based absolutely
that's really
so stupid
all right they're getting ready to get
it on
they're getting ready to get it on so
but we're gonna get right back to this
in the
right back to it cool boy catches him
with a left hook inside the middle of
the ring
ring walk in about 11 minutes right yep
top five heavyweight of all time i will
not put tyson fury's top five
heavyweight of all time
um
not even close be honest with you
you know
i've i've seen some of the greatest
heavyweights of my my
my life
and i don't think he he holds up to
but he's a good heavyweight
cool boy is taking the starch out of
um danny
left hook leaning catches danny by the
air
catches danny with the jab
side to side
so he pushes him back and he has danny
up against the ropes right about now
there well then a tight clinch
then he forces his way out cool boy
catches him with a check left hook and
spins to his left
to get some room
and he's back to jabbing
cool boy goes over the top and misses
in the center of the ring
cool boy catches them with a right
uppercut
and check left hook
back to
jabbing in the center of the ring
all right so cool boy guard is a little
bit over
you know from uh from a distance he
looks like
money mayweather not pretty boy floyd
pretty boy floyd was a different animal
a different beast that nobody wanted to
fight
looks like money may
nice jab nice right hand
from cool boy in the middle danny is
trying to box and goes underneath which
is smart
faint the top and go underneath and he
fainted the top and went for the right
hand
then he is following them and not
cutting the ring off and that's the
problem here cool boy is picking them
off spinning them holding them turning
them and waiting for the ref to break
them up lay back in the center of the
ring
cool boy throws a jab
and a straight right hand
jab
from cool boy
all right check left up
danny catches him check left up oh danny
catches him with a nice body shot and a
nice overhand right
good work
good work
15 seconds
danny tried to catch him with overhand
right
doesn't work
another round for cool boy
three rounds to two
this is going crazy
all right they're about to fight right
now
about to switch over to the fight
[Music]
this is ridiculous
it's a ton of people out there boy
ladies and gentlemen
michael buffer is here
all right
i know
that y'all want to finish talking about
cool boy
but we know where that's going
i'll be sadly wrong later
he said hey with the money team hell
yeah
let me see wow tyson fury not top five
really no okay so i'm talking about top
five you your question
your question i can give you heavy
weights that will destroy him
jack johnson
sonny
liston muhammad ali and which form you
want cassius clay muhammad ali or you
want muhammad ali uh uh on your cash
clay of muhammad ali you want george
foreman
before george foreman was the new
roly-poly george foreman or you want the
old draw from which one you want me to
use i can use either one of those you
want mike tyson before jail i have to
jail which mike tyson you want me to use
you want me to use linux lewis you want
me to be used riddick bo
what do you want me to do
to put in there with tyson fury
think about it just just think about it
yeah i didn't even listen i didn't even
get to the joe fraziers and and the joe
lewis and the rocky maciano's i didn't
even get to that stuff yet
right i'm not taking nothing away from
tyson fury tyson fury beat everybody
that was in front of him
but the best the best person that he
fought brought the best out of him and
that's deontay wilder right now take
this question is deontay wilder the best
heavyweight that you've ever seen
and if that heavyweight gave that heavy
weight that you're talking about the
best fights of his life
that answers your question
listen larry holmes is probably my
all-time favorite heavyweight
that gets the least amount of respect
larry holmes jab and right hand
alone was
murderous
we're not even talking about ken norton
who was a a minor uh heavyweight who
broke ally joe
no um no no no
no no
if sally
was no stop no no
back in the 90s
he would have got
slaughtered
slaughtered
[Music]
you think you think tyson fury's better
than riddick bo
what are you drinking i need i need what
you're drinking i need i need to have
what you're drinking and i
since we're here drinking together
please share
don't hide divide
come on now
he said wilder has the best right hand
of all time in your opinion
wilder
is probably one of the most
he has one of the best
knockout ratios
right
but would wilder still be wild if he
fought trevor berbick
if he for for ernie shavers
matchmaking goes into this
ray mercer yes
ray mercer was was an absolute beast
well we're going to talk about razer
ruddick yeah i mean we had a murderous
role
that these heavyweights had to fight
through to to to get
to the championship man
remember these dudes came along when the
heavyweight division was at its weakest
you know they go through this stuff
yo you know what wilder is the best bad
boxer of all time
because you have to ask yourself really
how the hell did he make it right
that right hand is the ultimate
equalizer eraser he's always down on
everybody's cards until boom
[Music]
shake shake the room boom
you gotta give deontay that respect man
self belief is something incredible that
teaches each and every last one first of
all he started late in life in boxing so
could you imagine if something if if
emmanuel stewart got a hold of him
if they if they taught him footwork
oh my god
with that natural power
something crazy
he said it's wilder than not while they
got two more fights in them aj in this
fight that he gonna do to get this belt
so right now
uh they're playing devin haney's music
that's a crazy crowd
will devin haiti be intimidated i don't
think uh olympic hopeful
um that has been all over nationals all
over the world
uh is going to be intimidated at
anything
but the walk to the ring
is like the length of a football field
this is absolutely disgusting they
should put them in a cart and drive from
there
you know why while the gas is out too
quick he does no road work
that's why
while the gas is out too quick you know
that right tell me the day that you ever
seen wilder jogging
you see him on a bike a lot
ask me the first time you seen him
jogging
that last fury fight was the first time
you seen him jumping rope
okay the difference between wilder and
uh fury while the fury actually does
road work
he has the stamina he actually his body
doesn't indicate exactly what
he is right so we can't look at his
flesh right
somebody sometimes your disposition your
your frame your genetics isn't
predetermined to to to look fantastic
right
so
you've seen his pops
his pops is an indication of what the
sun will look like right so again um
not fantastic genes when it comes to
looking like a model physique but that
non-model physique beat a lot of these
model physique dudes so let's not get it
twisted tyson fury had boxing
fundamentals iq and a chin hit a
rock-hard chin his chin is fantastic to
take those punches from deontay wilder
and to get up and still fight back and
give the best that he got i don't care
about the cheating and all that stuff i
mean i i kind of do but
at the same time you have to go in and
you have to give a a counter yourself so
by any means necessary get it done
let me say he only does swimming that's
right
you know it
you know it's cmac he only does swimming
tell the truth shame the devil
ortiz versus wilder i don't think they
make ot's versus wilder
ah that's that's not a good fight for
deontay wilder
you can throw a good job larry holmes
tried to help him as well larry holmes
is the best jab and heavyweight of all
time that is the absolute truth
larry holmes had a jab i saw larry
holmes throw a jab that cut the heavy
bag it was a brand new heavy bag
he threw a jab with a twist brought it
back and cut the heavy bag
that's how he he was catching people
with that jab
and then that stiff right hand come over
wow
wow
it's absolutely insane larry holmes is
so dope
yeah yeah fury is built like a trucker
yeah this is true
let me see he can't throw a good jab
larry holmes tried to help him this is
true
fury has
has breasts
that could distract anyone
that's highly disrespectful
unconscionable
all right so devin haney is coming out
right now
and they're gonna have him walk the
whole football field
he has a little pep in his step he's
smiling
he's seeing that crowd
you
you gotta respect him man he took short
money for long term game man devin haney
looked at the the long road to this and
said you know what he's energetic he's a
kid he's young he doesn't know any
better he doesn't know to be fearful he
doesn't know to say you know what um
any punch could be my last know what
he's going for is he's going for
greatness and he understands he's been
calling out every last person that he
can call out to get these belts he goes
out to a female he called our loma he
called out everybody so finally he
cornered uh cambodia's because cambosis
was gonna go with loma right so
he caught a cambosis loma can't fight
him right now
you know um you know because of what's
going on in the world and respect to
everything that's going on in the world
then please
make it out of this safe
but now he got cambosis and cambodia's
had to sign right so cambodia's couldn't
run
boy boy
here we go
his father's dear
and that's all i ever care about as a
father you know i want to be there for
my son any milestones that my sons have
um so i definitely
uh was kind of disheartened when his
father was in there but his father's
dead hell yeah give that boy that
strength
give that boy he when he came off the
air i felt him when he came off the the
plane he was walking on that tarmac and
he's like i'm here for my boy
man oh man do you know what type of
story this is a lifetime story man let
me see
any fight
in mexico those people prepared for him
in the moment
yeah his pops got that late visa yeah
shout out to any whoever helped him get
that late visa
so okay so the difference when i read
the chat i read the chat regular right
but if you watch from a caller if you
super chat then i say your name and all
that other stuff but
it is what it is you know i don't
actually do that stuff right now you
already paid for the fight i don't care
for y'all to you know do no super chats
you know stuff like that but on iop i
only see green why because i got on
shades
you see the difference right i got to do
my own work i got to read i got to do
the ball and stuff like that but
iop
be dark shades tamara
why because i've been up all night
he said hey
devin haney
is dressed like a splatoon stage
a rock with a doe
wow
naked peoples in here i gotta i gotta
time these naked people out man get out
of here
get out of here naked people
that's so nasty i got hit with naked
people
i only see green your facts yo
sponsored by nintendo
okay well you know what
both these guys made it happen this guy
had a long hard road um cambosis
he fought
everywhere that he needed to fight shout
out to the 51 people there with the 50
likes god bless you and everything that
you do man thank you for rocking with me
let's get it done man yo you know who i
like
on the low one of my my my favorite
little internet dudes that i watch 1090
jake
yo when he come on he black
you're rocking with me i'm rocking with
you this is 1090 i love it i actually go
crazy i think that dude is dope go ahead
come campbell says he walking like
somebody stole his money
when we outside right now
oh man you got to have a little pep in
your step when you're going down there
that that ring to get to uh
to get to that ring it's a football
field they got to walk
that's a lot of people there
that gate is dude
yeah yeah
he win it today cambos is about that
smoke man cam boss is about that smoke i
you gotta respect old boy he bought that
spoke man he said little code words and
stuff like you know like hey boy i chose
you boy stuff like sound like mr t hey
boy i chose you boy
[Music]
man oh man here he go he ready his nose
look red already like he got him punched
in his nose already
you know what i'm talking about right
you know what i'm talking about your
game
dmx versus 50 cent
you know i love 50 cent man i can't lie
man can't lie hustle his ambition boy
oh man
standing at the ropes he's feeling it
man he's feeling it man he feeling it
this is what it is
that is a big damn ring for these little
dudes
that only favors devin haney
oh boy
who is this referee don't trust him
never seen him before is that a local
is that a local
he said def jam vendetta
50k in the ring
is it 50k in the arena
possibly
possibly
devin looks ready
that's his daddy there man
yo let me ask you a question but you
know anytime you had to fight right so i
i never had my daddy all right so my i
mean later on in life i mean i had me
had to make me right pause um but my
daddy was never there so anytime i had
to fight i had to fight you know alone
or i had my cousin with me right so
anytime my older cousin come up do you
know what level of strength that you get
like
right
so could you imagine how he feel his pop
showed up he got that tiger at him boy
he paused he outside he's about to do it
he looking like floyd mayweather
and roy
you
this this
yo who got goosebumps who got goosebumps
with me you got goosebumps i got
goosebumps too man yo who got goosebumps
with me baby
oh my god yes they talking to each other
oh my god he got a roll right there
hello
surprise
open your eyes we here
hey yeah
the outside man this is what i'm talking
about
uh yo if you don't got goosebumps right
now you are not a boxing fan this is
goosebumps territory right here boy you
know both of these dudes is here to
bring it man nobody's here to back down
oh man shout out to michael buffer still
doing it still doing it
that is he is literally
the greatest announcer alive
literally
you know you the greatest when you can
get your brother
to go to a different sport
and get it's time like yo
do you understand how great you are
that your brother can get a job do it
come on man you're the greatest of all
time
george got
cold he's got a cold his nose is red
yeah okay
check his blood later
outside with no shirt on
careful scared deal
with a rangy educated jet
we gonna see what he can deal with and
what he can deal with right now though
i'm gonna tell you this this first four
rounds is gonna tell you exactly who
could deal with what and what to do with
who
here we go
all i ever cared about
is when losing draw
devin haney pops is there with him now
because he walked him into the gym
together
and they went on this journey together
and he's always been there he stepped
out the way for his son
you know just to be his manager he told
him he don't want to have any hindrance
in his career
humble man let his his son grow into a
man
beautiful
he looks good he looks ready
he looks good he looks ready
devin looks good he looks ready
no i'm not picking up mario strikers
nah i'm not picking up mario strikers
but um i'm pretty sure my song got
bothered me about it yo i haven't played
my switch in a minute i'm waiting for um
whatchamacallit to be honest with you
breath of the wild too
but at the same time i'm like i just
posted pictures y'all saw the painting
right
i'm really transforming my whole house
renovations and all that other stuff uh
renovated the whole foyer uh painted
upstairs downstairs every room renovated
two rooms upstairs uh doing a whole
bunch of stuff man so really haven't had
a chance you know to do anything street
fighter 6 hell yes street fighter six
i saw that and went absolute nuts i saw
the stream
shout out to playstation yo i love where
playstation shows multi-plat stuff it's
beautiful
when the next kos all right the next qas
is coming very soon i'm still working
with graphic guard to finish the intro
we had one intro didn't really like it
too much they touched hands that's it
they about to get it on let's go cam
bose's wife looks scared
excuse me let's get those burps out
let's go
i'm i'm amped up
oh yeah to i had i had to record those
videos somebody asked me to record those
videos while i was on vacation
all right check it out
check it out this about to start this is
it right here your boy gets a shot
here we go
here we go
in the center of the ring
right now
you got devin haney already started with
the jab
all right
cam bolsters is staying on the outside
not coming in which i find kind of crazy
because remember when he fought to
female he ran straight out
all right so
devin is uh shooting a jab
and if uh cambodia stays on the outside
like he's doing i don't see him winning
this fight at all
so devin is keeping him at distance
right now with faints
but they just warming up getting to know
each other
right now
all right cambodia throws a jab
devin is on the front foot
but he's faint and he's not going in too
hard for
right so he's right there on the front
foot
all right so you see the the strategy of
cambosis is to beat him in to counter
off of anything that devin does so devin
right now is doing a lot of faints
and he's not throwing no right hands yet
everything is fainting fainting leaning
in
to see exactly what cambodia's going to
do
they're missing jabs all right so devin
finally connects with a jab
and cam bolsters tries to hit him when
devon comes in devon walks him to the
ropes pushes them to the ropes
and
cambos is leans on devon's neck
they're back in the center of the ring
they're very small this is a very huge
ring this ring is very big
all right back to the jab from uh devin
haney
all right straight right hands i mean
straight jabs from uh devin haney
cambosis hits devin haney behind the
head
while he was in the clinch referee warns
i'm told uh devin he watched the head we
had a minute left in the round devin
haney throws a jab
devin haney throws a jab
cambo system might try to steal the last
half of the round
all right he does that he throws a
couple of shots
throws a right hand over the top
crowd goes crazy
referee is making him all about himself
and he's warning cambodia's again he's
showing that he's tough on cambodia's
time-out time back in
back in the center of the ring
26 seconds to go
all right devon keeps jab into
cambodia's body
and cambodia's
all right straight over the top by devin
devin waltz can boast his back
good strategy
nice jab straight jab
oh
cam bosses tries the right hand at the
end round is over i got to give that
again to devin
devin
all right got that channel out of there
george's wife looked nervous yeah she do
look nervous
please from fordham holly's king what's
going on pace
do you have the lay on seems like you're
30 seconds
to a minute behind
well actually no i'm watching it on um
sky sports
so their network might be you know
behind a little bit
because remember of the zone package
that i have so the zone package that i
have does that
52 watching 55 likes that's what's up
good looking
all right so they back round two they're
back in the center of the ring
all right so
then really not as much fireworks as teo
female
versus uh cambosis devin is putting the
jab stiff out there
stiff cambosis tries to punch over the
top
devin is back to the jab all right now
cambodia's is waking up and he's trying
to counter everything that devin does so
but devin is sticking that jab
and devin tries the right hand over the
top
but devin is showing me that he's gonna
box off his front foot he's not boxing
off his back foot he's boxing off his
front foot and that's all that i asked
for
right
all right put some power into your shots
you try the right hand cam boosters try
to come under the bottom with that
all right good
he's mauling
um cambosis against the ropes that's
pushing his uh his gloves into
campbell's face on the clinch
all right jab from devon
keeps a low jab
and he brings it up to the top
nice nice oh
right hand by kambos of cambosis
measured devin caught devon with a right
hand
did he hurt him
is devin
hurt no
he spun him he didn't hit him in the
back of the head he could have hit him
that was a good thing oh and then it
devin
he's back to jabbing but cam bosses
caught him with a good hand
excuse me
nice jab nice jab
cam bosses of what haney is doing is
he's giving up his height and he does
this a lot he dips very low and he's
susceptible to short left hooks inside
and
um mid shots
that's why um cambosis swung low right
there to catch devin dipping into a shot
all right so they're back in the center
of the ring again and devin is back on
his jab now cambos is trying to do
a mimic of the philly shell
i'm trying to show his shoulder and
moving close while catching and pitching
puts his hands back up to bring the
defense in to get devin to go to his
body but devin sticks to the gamepad and
sticks to the jab
all right so when he jabs devin is
stepping into the jab but he's not
walking into that straight right hand
that cambodis is trying to set him up
for
devin steps back
cambosis is trying to push the attack
devon walks him back to the center of
the ring i see the game playing 20
seconds left
in the first round
and he walks him back again
to the ropes
referee is too much about him
ken bowser misses devon catches them
with a 1-2
round is over
nice check left hook
the devin got two rounds to me in my
opinion oh you felt there was one one
that's what's up
yeah
cambodia's got their counters ready
let me see kel yeah gambo says is
counting good devin needs to settle down
and
before he runs into something i honestly
believe that too right so what what
devin
is is doing and what i'm saying is
uh devin is trying to bait him but he's
also he's cognizant of what the refs are
seeing right doesn't that play a part
into this right here this is the thing
so you'll both see a 1-1 i saw a 2-0 to
be honest with you with devin but um
because he ducked under that shot that
shot i thought he got caught with he
ducked under that shot
but again one won this fear it could be
you know i got it uh two zero devon
but let's keep going
i'm gonna i'm gonna get a little score
card a little tally
so i could be putting that up i got a
1-1 good yeah i got it sp i got a 2-0 uh
haney
okay now uh cam bosses came out with a
nice overhand right and a left hook but
they both missed devin back on his jab
and he's standing there like a racer in
the middle
right so he's
there you go
oh he's trying to throw the right hand
over the top so he's trying to disguise
the right hand
behind the jab by leaping in and
bringing it close to his face
all right so they're backing us into the
ring
and devin is back to work in the jab
right now
cambosis is taking a step back to bring
devin in to counter as a counterpuncher
you're supposed to do that
all right cambodia's goes to his body
devon goes back to the japan to
cambodia's face
and
they're just posturing right now in the
center of the ring devon is walking cam
boosters back to the ropes like he's
supposed to let the ref break him up get
right back to javen
all right
so they're back to the center of the
ring
and haney's back to jab and cam bosses
throws uh left to the body hits uh devon
on the hip brings a
right to the body and left to the chest
back to the jab from devin haney gavin
he catches him with a left right left
good combination from devin haney
catches him with a stiff left right left
beautiful oh left right hand he caught
him with a stiff right hand devin haney
catches cambosis with a stiff right hand
cambosis is smart and punches devin
haney in the chest as he tries to come
in devin haney's back to the jab
uh cambodia's goes back to his jab
beautiful beautiful work by both
fighters
uh-huh
devin haney is boxing oh right hand oh
he catches campbell's he's got
combustors up against the ropes straight
right hands and he throws another right
hand over the top one minute left in the
round folks
right now devin haney is putting in that
work that we talking about off the front
foot this is what i said he needed to do
and this is exactly what he's doing
he has his arm down though he needs to
have that in a defensive posture he's
trying to catch him um lacking all right
straight jab cambos has tried to counter
uh-huh cambosis is taking too many
straight punches
okay
cambodia's can't get off his shots like
he wants to because devin is not there
when he needs to return devin attacks
him to the body cambodia tries to
counter devon's not there
over the top cambosis i mean
devin haney over the top right hand
cambosis is missing
largely with his shots
and devin is fainting him devin has both
his hands down now this is the same way
linares caught him he needs to have his
hands up this man is dangerous at all
times and he catches them with a check
left hook at the end of the round i have
devin up three rounds to zip but y'all
got devin at what two one yo what you're
gonna say cambodia's won that round two
let's see let's go
hanging around
easy
see that's what i told you see mac i
told you devin had to take the crowd out
of the fight can he do it will he do it
he must do it he must box off his front
foot he must sneak that right hand in he
must shoot the gaps i told you cambosis
has holes in his defense but when he's
aggressive he can actually make
opportunity for for himself cambosis is
not being aggressive he's being too
weary for these shots
speed kills definitely definitely speed
kills but timing kills speed and it's
more timing because i do believe
cambosis is faster but i believe devin
haney has a better timing and that
better timing leads to that jab and that
overhand right that's why you saw him do
a left right left and it's crazy when
you land that it's beautiful when you
see it
let's go we right back at it again he
back in the center of the ring so right
now devin haney has a high guard and
when you pull a hard guard in that's
what you're doing to bring it into a
counter punches father probably told him
go to high guard so now he's back into
high guard now he has mid uh mid jab mid
jab from the waist right hand is at the
chin level to go shoot over the top
uh cam bosus is flinching off of
everything devin does so devin throws a
straight jab
and flinches uh cambosis
see
they're back in the center of the ring
again
there's a lot of faints all right
cambosis tries to throw that left but he
keeps missing over the top wildly
all right
and his feet just got crossed up right
there i don't know what that was but
devin is back to his jab cambosis
counters with two jabs of his own
i think cambosis is too busy to worry
about the retaliation of devin
actually all right so back to the
straight jab from uh devon cambos is
catches devin close with a straight
right hand inside
um
did he catch his shoulder his chest i
couldn't see
right
but they're back at it cambosis is back
to reacting off of everything nice
counter
good all right get loose there we go
devin is trying to line them up for that
straight right hand cambosis is trying
to do the same devon goes back to the
jab
they're back in the center of the ring a
devon goes around cambodia's high guard
with a right hand
uh and cambod goes back to the low guard
midgard
all right straight jab
from devin
devin catches him with a left hook going
in walks him back to the ropes doesn't
let the ref
do anything unless the ref break them up
back in the center devon jules a jab
cambosis tries to throw a right hand to
the body
slides off his back off of devon's back
back in the center of the ring
off of a clinch one minute to go
devin is jabbing
back in the center of the ring devin is
jabbing he throws a right hand he throws
a left hook he catches cam boson he
gives it uh okay cam bosses catches
devon with a right hand and cam bosses
goes back to getting jabbed
all right right hand left hook they both
trading punches now now the fight is
heating up now we get into a fight we
got cambos stepping forward trying to
come in
uh he caught devon right there he's
coming in with some punches he's trying
to catch devin this is the only way he
can win he has to maul devin he can't
allow devin to keep punching oh okay now
he's coming in there we go that's the
cam boosters that i wanted to see i want
to see a cam boost if they got a fight i
want to see the honey badger let's get
it
devin back to the jab all right
did cambosis win the round at the end
quite possibly he could have done it i
think he's he quite possibly is a
there's a possibility
all right let me see let me break this
up right here
let me get this out of here these dudes
keep coming back
all right
nobody wanna
let me see okay let me see what happened
remember for 18 months i appreciate the
coverage thank you brother i appreciate
it yeah for old devon that's what's up
echelon 7 of darkness with 1.99 super
chat excellent play by play lord king
thank you so much 100 percent do
appreciate you brother thank you so much
devin hanley haney's jab is definitely
on fleek right now man i can't lie that
was a tough one to call i can't lie you
but devin haley did so much work the
first half of the fight then you got to
say the last 30 seconds uh cambodia's
woke up
i got to give it to devin haney but i'm
going to give cambodia's one round so i
got a three rounds to one
all right so we back we into round five
this is when the fight starts to heat up
right here we go now
here we go people
all right cam bosses feel comfortable
enough now to come in
right all right and devin is all right
jabbing straight to the body right hand
straight to the body
oh nice jab from devin oh nice uppercut
from devin
caught him in between when cambosis was
trying to counter all right so devin is
uh keeps the jab his right hand close
uh to his face and
back to jabbing beautiful beautiful
uh jab from devon
cambosis came in two shots to the body
and devon walks him back to the ref
breaks him up
back to it devin back to the jab
cam boston tries to come over the top
with a jab i mean with a right hand and
gets jabbed again by devin devin's jab
seems to be the deciding factor in this
fight
you cannot lie mccain bosus is still
trying he throws a jab and he throws the
right hand to the body it's on devin's
back but again
the cambosis holds on and makes sure the
reps break them up
back to the center of the ring
devon is boxing off his back foot right
now and he's allowing uh cambosis to
come in
without a jab cambosis is walking him
without a jab all right all right devin
is back to his jab back in the center of
the ring
all right with a high guard all right
cambodia throws the one two three
all right devin is back to jab and
cambodia's goes to devin's body while
devon goes to the jab he was about to
throw a right hand but he caught
campbell's gamble since the smart one
minute left in the round devin is back
to popping his head back with that jab
it is uh something to see it's like a
whip
he's whipping him with this jab they're
in close they're working and clothes
devin walks him back to the referee
breaks up the fight
cambosis tries to come back in the
middle of the ring you have 43 seconds
left in the round
cambo is coming to life now i see what
he's trying to do
all right
devin catches him all right cambodia's
catches devil with a left hook
and they back and center the ring devon
is back to jabbing
and he goes to a one-two cambosis goes
to the body devon goes to
the right over the top cambosis comes
over the top
and
they walk all right now they get broken
it was a clinch again
back to a jab
cambosis is trying to steal around
it won't work this round i give that
round to devin
man that was really good
yeah devon
what i what i expect from devon though
is to be sharper with the right hand
right he's not sharp and what i expect
from cambosis is to understand
that he has to start parrying the jab as
he comes in he has to stop hurrying so
if you're not going to jab with the
jabber don't
right parody jab coming in so catching
pitch come in one
after he perry's one
dip low go straight to the body right
when you go straight to the body bring
it back up to perry and then go straight
over the top he's not doing that and
he's the shorter man and he should be
right but he's trying to catch devin
coming in outstanding coverage is always
king keep it up thank you no more uh for
a member for 10 months that's right lord
silva thank you so much might be light
work for devon tonight might not man it
might not remember the fight is wrong
stuff can happen stuff can change
remember linares caught him what round
was that like 9 10.
remember
if devon has a lapse of of of focus
anything can happen
he has to be focused he has to be
supremely focused and i think he's
supposed to stay on top of george but
he's not
and and that's what i see is the problem
all right one two three from devin haney
he pushes george back
they're back in the middle of the ring
right hand
by by haney
oh jab oh that jab is disgusting it's
nasty
all right so cambodia gave up on his jab
and he's going to the body
into the chest of devin haney good there
you go kambos's all right cambodia
switched to southpaw for a second and he
switched back to orthodox
devin
haney walks them back they go to a
clinch
haney goes right back into his posture
cambosis goes right back into his
posture
all right
nice jab
from haney
tried to throw a right hand
nice stiff jab
stay in the center of the ring uh-huh
cambodia tries to counter the cambosis
is getting marked up by these jabs
all right so again on his left side he's
his face is red on the left side
devin is fainting him inside close and
he's bringing the right hand over the
top
all right devin haney is timing him
perfectly
oh
cam bosses throws a one two three
uh probably the three hit but the one
two missed all right oh nice left hook
from cambosis he catches devin haney
closest to the rope stephan haney walks
him to the rough breaks him up
and he better not lose focus because
like i told you before it takes a couple
of seconds you lose focus you lose your
life very easy very easily all the work
that you put in can go oh nice short
right hand in close from devin haney
while he was clinched
one minute left in the round
oh straight right hand to the body of uh
uh
of cambosis from devin haney
back back to
the clinch
referee says come on man cut out cut it
out
the back in the center
all right i'm surprised at cambos's
strategy to try to outbox the boxer here
and it doesn't make any sense all right
there in the clinch right now waiting
for the ref to break them up
and the ref breaks them up
and they back to the second back in the
center of the ring
all right 13 seconds left
all right oh oh campbell punches him in
the ding ding
oh
straight left from devon cambosis tries
to come over the top
all right best punch from cambos is that
round with the ding ding bing bong
but you got respect devin haney's for
giving him that educated jab is
something disgusting
left hand blaze yeah i don't like
yeah devin haney legs right
dame dolla had to fight yeah you're for
sure six so um i'm giving it five one
uh so far five one
and i like it i like it i like it
he said it like kick the mini ding ding
shout out eddie murphy
okay let me see
yeah yeah yeah y'all know that y'all
know that y'all know that anybody that
knows those old
old comedy shows there you go
all right so yeah
excuse me
let's get it we right back at it again
let's get it they're back in the center
ring
all right we're looking at round seven
this is ridiculous we got five rounds to
one
uh devin haney tries to catch cambosis
with a short in uppercut he goes to a
high guard and he switches he goes right
back to jab in cambodia's counters and
stops david haney from throwing the
right hand all right now cambodia is
jabbing his way in
all right cambodia's left side of his
face is a little bit swollen from jazz
but that's up to be expected they have
inswell for that devon hanging catches
them with a leap and left hook and a
straight jab
back in the center of the ring
devin haney is flicking the jab
uh huh cambosis comes in and he tries to
maul devin haney good catches him in the
ding ding again he learned i'm telling
you right now
i'm telling you right now
yeah yeah we showing our age yeah yeah
we proud of it
all right good job from devon good job
from devon in the center of the ring
come on campbell so slip that jab use
that shoulder slip that jab get inside
pop them with that left do something
okay there we go throw that left he got
blocked but throw that left all right
gambo throws the right hand in close
all right come back devin back to
jabbing in the center of the ring and
throws the right hand steps away
all right
he's on the back foot right now and he
spun uh cambosis around back to the
center of the ring
cambosis is moving in he throws a right
to devin's body nice shot
good he throws a jab catches
devin
all right nice jab from cambosis
it's back to the center of the ring
devon comes back with his jab comes back
with his jab doesn't throw the right
hand
cambosis catches devon with a right hand
coming in
one minute left in the round
so again they're right back at it devil
haines back to the jab cam bosus comes
over the top with a right hand now
cambosis is uh stalking devin haney
devin haney fights off the rope catches
the cambosis with a double jab and into
a clinch and they break it right now
back into the center of the ring
oh haney tries to catch him with a left
hook devin uh campbell since catches him
with a body uh shot a left hand
tight
one two from devon
catches cambos and cambosis throws a
forearm into devin on the on the break
oh nice job from devon
14 seconds left devon throws a one two
catches cam bosses he catches kambos
cambo since tries the right hand over
the top tries another right hand over
the top throws another elbow in close on
the clinch and the round is broken up i
give that round again to devin
man oh man
so we're looking at 6-1 devin so far in
my opinion but they probably got them
all leaving because they out there in
australia hi mike g'day
good night mate
looks like somebody's going home
yo they got a hole they got a whole ice
pack on the side of his head like the
whole side of his head
he has a whole ice pack he's like
devin's out there doing a lot of work i
i'm trying to fight but i really can't
see him with this side right here
said blimey crikey
crikey that guy's jab is really
[Laughter]
cutting out man
[ __ ] crikey that young guy can really
throw them blows
[Music]
yeah that educated hand is right
and he's standing there boy standing
there ready round's about to start let's
get it let's get it
come on cam bosses come on man come on
man
something give me something to work with
baby come on
that's what i'm talking about
devin is is baiting them in
see that's how god is god works funny
because can you imagine devin with the
power tank
oh no no no no no
they in the center of the ring round
eight
devin is throwing a one two
cambosis is at the end of the jab
camouflage throws a short left hook
devon catches it he does it again devin
catches it again
and dips out the way he's trying to
catch cambodia's coming in to catch
cambodia's with a
a right hand throws a one two then he
goes another one
all right cambodia's face is looking uh
kind of moshed on that side he's not cut
caught him with a right hand
if if devon hit a little bit harder
cambodia's whole side of his face will
be struggling shut
but right now right now
good right hand
by uh cambodia's good job by kim boses
all right
devin is circling back to the center of
the ring does a sweeping right hand uh
cambodia goes into a high guard and
tries to catch him off balance and
they clinch and they walk until the ref
breaks him up somebody has to stop that
dance and it has to be cambodia's
because all it does is give devon more
time
all right and cambodia's uh devon spins
cam bosses towards the corner and goes
right back to the jab he's jabbing him
literally to definitely throws a right
hand over the top oh cambosis throws a
right hand after a left hook
he's trying but he gets caught with a
straight jab
all right he goes right to the body
cambosis does but he gets caught with a
straight jab his head keeps snapping
back this round i think his head doesn't
snap back the most
that was crazy because his leg didn't
look right after his head got snapped
back right there cam bosses
all right they back in the center to the
ring why does he keep going into the
center of the ring with this guy and
devin goes over the top stop following
him and cut off the ring man
go to a high guard and fight him
all right so there we go oh short left
hook right hand by devin devin spins out
with no problem we have 26 seconds left
all right cambosis is on the attack he's
trying to attack devin and devon keeps
throwing a 1-2 over the top cambosis is
trying to walk in but devin throws a
nice jab right there all right so
cambosis tries to come in but he doesn't
get him he's screaming he's trying to
get amped up the crowd trying to get him
to go
but devon throws a jab spins right back
out straight right hand
again
another round to devin and the crowd
thought they saw something that wasn't
there
it just wasn't there
you got 16 devin hayden cambosis looks
frustrated yeah man
yeah this this this is a beatdown
king what's the name of your statue
podcast again kos
you just go to iron lords podcast and
then go down to the selections you'll
see attic show you see uh kos you see
um
uh what's going to call the combat talk
with the king
uh
and sunday beat down this is ridiculous
floyd devin wilder george is starting to
look frustrated yeah
don't really start yo you stupid
a-oh yeah
king what is the name of your statue
podcast again i want to check it out
it's called kos this natural podcast
show is called kos
just click the link on iron lord's
podcast and go right down and then
you'll see like all my shows
definitely joining hell is this what's
up
yeah
all right here we go
oh there we go all right so devon throws
uh one two
oh nice uppercut inside from devon
back in the center of the ring
[Music]
so he's standing oh straight right hand
from devon catches cambodia's cold
all right cambodia's comes over the top
with her right hand
tries to catch him
all right so they back to the center
ring
oh straight right hand from devon
man devin is laying the cambosis is
completely frustrated at this point in
time
you know
all right so we back at the center of
the ring
and devin is close to the ropes
uh huh cambodia says there you go
campbell's oh
no spun them on the floor
devin fell on the floor after a trip
but definitely got a little mouse under
his eye
all right he didn't get that from
nothing
all right jab from uh devon back in the
center of the ring cambosis is going
forward he's swung he missed devin spun
out of the way
devon is back to the center of the ring
straight right hand oh one two three
from devon jeez and a short left hook
catches him coming in
cambosis is throwing his jab about time
man
about time but then he keeps taking a
half step back keeps giving devon
respect devon tries to take a short
uppercut and he catches him
with a left foot cambosis catches uh
devin with a right hand all right
cambodia's just throwing a one two
all right this must be cambodia's
strategy go late round
catches them in the ding ding again we
right back at it
all right devin's back with the jab cam
both sisters back to oh nice right hand
from cam bosses knight right right hand
from devin
okay here we go i guess they're gonna
fight for these belts now now it's time
to fight for these belts devin is
throwing the jab right there with his
hands at his waist and he might let get
caught by something campbell's oh right
hand from devon
devin throws a jab cambosis tries to
counter
devin is back to jabbing
back off his back foot told you that's
not good for devon
24 seconds left in the round referee
breaks him up devin is doing the
smartest thing in the world hold him to
the referee breaks you up and cam bosus
is not fighting like a tiger while he's
inside oh
nice right hand from devon
cambodia throws a jab cambosis is trying
to stop
but now he's trying to maul him but
devon holds in the toe
the round is over that's another round
for devin devin throws the one twos and
he catches cambosis with these shots
cambosis is trying to be aggressive but
he's being ineffective with his
aggressiveness his aggressiveness is
coming up short and it's not cool yeah
now i know
i give them eight one how about that
cambodia's trying to take it detainee
knees are you stupid
cambodia's neck is probably killing him
that's why he keeps
he's taking a step back you stupid
have you updated kos in like 10 months
or something i thought you did a
separate podcast with like five of the
stats yeah i used to do um with dcx dcx
stop and um i'm just doing my show now
kos
has taken a lot of shots to the face
paul's yeah he definitely did
yeah i used to do a statue show with kos
um but you know we talked that was on
friday nights but being that i'm doing
this on saturday doing iop on sunday and
i'm going to be doing kos on wednesday
and i ain't got no time to be honest
with you
but i love dcx and uh you know when they
come back we'll be working on some stuff
and doing some stuff but yes that's
that's dcx is my family that's my statue
family my community love them completely
they in the center of the ring
right now
so all right
round ten
all right so right now
you got uh kambos of trying to come in
trying to go over the top and they
telling them yo you're losing you got to
go in there fight you got to take it to
devin haney devin haney
uh boxing off the back foot his timing
is looking like a little bit off he
catches cambosis
with the jab coming in
catches cambodians with another jab
beautiful beautiful work in the center
of the ring nice jab cambos is using his
arm as a measuring stick trying to catch
devin with that right hand he catches
devin with the left hook
all right so devin is
standing in the center of the ring he
tries to throw a right hand he throws a
left leg cambo goes to his body
all right nice jab from uh devin
again
and then back in the center of the ring
uh
nice uh counter left from devon overhand
right from cambosis
sent to the ring again jab by devin
oh
job by devon
cambosis throws the right hand short
inside
they're back in the center of the ring
chad by devin
cambodia goes over the top and he holds
devin arm he tries to land his shot
he's trying to do anything to win devin
can't complain he's throwing his head
he's chicken winging him he's doing
everything the referee is telling him to
calm down
one minute left in the round
devin has to get upset and he has to
fight
jab stiff jabs from devon stiff jabs
from devon standing in the middle of the
ring center on the center logo
stiff rat stiff jabs
cambosis throws ahead
devin throws the right hand cambosis
tries to throw a right over the top
oh straight right hand from devon
jab to the body from devon
straight job from devon
cambosis falls in
referee breaks them up 17 seconds to go
in the round
oh
one two
from devon
one two by devin
cambo tries to come over the top tries
to steal around
nothing really i mean again it's
ineffective aggressiveness from cambosis
i give that round to devin so we're
looking at what um 10-1
is that 10-1
ridiculousness absolutely ridiculousness
somebody in this corner has to be real
with him and give him real boxing
instruction
you know um oh yeah so i was saying nine
one right so you sp good looking
nine look at that he steps in
and he catches him with a smooth
jab but he holds that hand boy he's
trying to freaking punch his head off
he's trying to do anything you got to
respect little man for getting in there
man and doing his best
all right here we go back in the center
ring round 11 we got two rounds to go
devin haney is boxing off the back foot
cambosis is coming in
all right devin haney is walking him
back with two double jabs
excuse me
jambos goes over the top with a right
hand
all right back to the jab by cambosis i
mean by um devin haney
oh devin haney throws a
double jab and faint
fake left hook cambosis countess with a
double jab of his own
devil haney throws a double jab again
up and low he's varying the height
stiff uh uppercut
from devin devin is throwing the jab
spinning cambosis
they back inside the center of the ring
devin is spinning them and they're
breaking them up
okay
back to the jab
and they walk them back devin is walking
them back
as well
right back in the center
all right
all right back to the jabbing
devin is doing a supreme jab
this is absolutely outstanding folks
nice jab in the center of the ring he
tries to check left hook and he's right
behind kambos
all right cambos is absolutely
frustrated
at this point in time right now
all right devin
is along the ropes moving off the back
foot jabs
cambosis when he catches cambodia's with
a jab cam bosses catches them with a
right hand cambo tries to catch him with
a left hook devon blocks it referee
breaks up the clinch one minute left
devon's back to
jabbing oh right hand left hook devon
spins off the ropes
very frustrating
jab straight to it
jab straight to the body
jab jab straight to the top straight to
the bottom
oh straight right hand from devin
left hook from devon
jab from devon center the ring right
hand from devon
all right 16 seconds left in the round
jab from devon
cambosis is trying to come but devin is
dancing on him cambo is trying to step
it in
all right
beautiful beautiful beautiful
that round was completely devin that was
the most one-sided round of the whole
damn fight
uh
gave the kilo
kid
six one six one nine thank you for the
two dollar uh super chat
i appreciate your call join these fights
king thank you so much man i do
appreciate it yo frustrations is hot
definitely
100 suicide kings let me see let me see
who's that is
guessing king doesn't do a weekly statue
thing anymore i guess do these busy
facts though facts though but soon i'm
gonna do a weekly thing
listen kos is gonna be a weekly thing
that's gonna be every wednesday it's
gonna be a call and show the same thing
and i'm going to be giving away a whole
bunch of stuff man i got sponsors and
stuff lined up so it's definitely going
to be dope kos is king of the statues
that's going to be there right now we
doing combat talk with the king so i
gotta get an overlay man i'm gonna
overlay i'm gonna call through i'm gonna
have your calling and we're gonna get
this this is round 12. let's go let's
see if somebody got something in their
hands to fight with let's go
last round devin haney got both his
hands up
cambosis is walking out stalking the
crowd is on his feet cambodia starts
with a jab
daint devin is on his back foot
he does a check left hook he steps back
he steps forward
steps back back to his jab
jambosis is trying to come in
devon is moving from side to side
fainting cambosis is trying to come in
right now
cambodia's is trying
devon is jabbing left hook right hand
jeez this is disgusting cambodia falls
into the ropes
missing a shot
gamboses throws a one two devon blocks
both shots
all right devin slides in gives him the
shoulder walks until the referee breaks
them up
that's a that's a level of submission
you're supposed to have step back and
punch
you don't do it
all right devon throws a one two
cambosis he pushes cam bosses back with
the shoulder goes back to the jab
cambosis is taking a lot of jabs this
fight
all right devon is back to the one two
cambosis tries to land to the body
devon walks him back to the referee
breaks him up and a referee breaks up
the
fight there we go they're back in the
center of the ring cambodia's tries to
come devon steps from left to right
catches him with a check left hook then
cambodia tries to come in devon catches
him with a jab devin spins cam bosses
misses wildly with a left hook
that was a mid left hook too i don't
know how you missed that
all right stepped in jab dev steps in
holds and walks them until the refs
breaks it up you have a minute left in
this round
devin looks clean he looks fresh
except for that little bump under his
right side oh cambosis catches him with
a double uppercut inside uh devin
catches him with a left hook
devon is looking to give up this round
to be honest with you and i think that's
a mistake at all times never give up any
round he's stepping from side to side
all right
cambodia tries to throw some shots devin
pushes them off we got 37 seconds left
chambos is trying
but again
devin is back to throwing it from jabs
cam boosters catches
devon holds them referee breaks up the
the grab the clinch
back to the jab cam bosses comes over
the top
nothing's there referee breaks up the
clinch
all right
left foot
left [ __ ] by devon
good fight
good fight good fight
um
good fight
i give that round to cambosis uh tend to
be honest with you
same thing suicide kings
now would they rob him would we see the
fixes in
this is what we all came to folks
because we knew that devin wasn't gonna
knock him out right so we knew that
devin could box him right did we know if
uh uh this guy was gonna get frustrated
was he gonna show the same aggression he
didn't show the same level of aggression
of t or fema i think teal female made it
easy
um
it was it was a master class it was a
master class it was a master class a
absolute
ridiculous master class of a fight shout
out to the 57 people still watching
that's what's up i do appreciate it
share it out to your friends let people
know
uh combat talk with the king
the professional fan i'm giving you the
best play by playing the game man
there's no lie to that i'm gonna tell
you what's going on in the ring at all
times because i actually know what's
going on in the ring at all times
let me see
all i heard was jab clinch fight yo that
is no lie and that's exactly what it was
it was jab clinch but if you're devin
haney what you're supposed to do jab
right hand clinch right
he he doesn't have superpower so what
you what you do you have the oncoming
bull if he ran into a couple of shots
but as all the jabs that devin landed
right that lets you know look at
cambodia's face
now remember cambodia's face after he
fought um
to a female
remember how he looked
all right
it was a syriac versus little man
then why'd you why you went for rolly oh
no i told you i okay i picked rolly
for for for pure chaos i okay tank wins
and then what like what really right
what really right
but rolly wins he upsets the apple cart
sometimes i'll just look for a little
fun i i like this loudmouth kid that
maybe you know maybe you catch light in
the bottle who cares
i knew tank was supposed to win tape
catch me knock them out but
what if right so i was it was just a fun
bet plus the odds was crazy i put down a
hundred dollars i went back eight
hundred dollars okay you can take a
hundred dollars i don't give a hell
right disposable income
i don't think that fight happened
i don't think lomo versus haney happened
you got to say lumo won't be ready until
next year right if that happens
all right um
i don't know
i don't think that fight happens because
cambodia has a rematch clause in this
fight if he lose right so the rematch
clause comes in he has to devin has to
go back to australia to replicate what
he did here let's say he doesn't
replicate it that means that they have
another fight in order right so no that
llama fight is not there
what about lomo versus shakur stevenson
i think she called boxes his head off
his shoulders
but lomo's that dude i don't know man
until female need to uh to get in there
and start making it happen timo tia
female versus haney that's a better
fight
i'm gonna tell you this teal female
ain't gonna sit there and do this
that's not gonna happen
and when losing george here females
gonna walk and i thought tia female's
biggest problem was his arrogance after
he beat lomo he thought he's going to be
the highest dude on on hog i think
that's the curse of all those belts at
one time
is haney about to be a superstar
i don't think so
first of all he commands too much money
all right um because he's going to go
back to the zone after this because he's
fighting with top rank he's going to
he's going to go back to
the zone he commands too much money
and i don't think they market it haney
properly
aka cali kid 619 for the two dollar
super chat thank you is haney about to
be a superstar
hold on
hold on
yes
they all had it they didn't rob our boy
he got he got it he did it he got it
done he got it done
yo we've watched history this year and i
hope his father be classy i hope his
father be classy right now i hope his
father is classy right now
um
with them don't just don't scream on him
the the kid went there and shut them out
they went to foreign land you got to
respect them he took short money and
better on himself
and and and that's what's up
he said cog versus saab next
i'm really from oakland though
i called you definitely did call it man
i mean you know but ray charles saw that
happening now you got dudes upset
fighting you know listen man it's not
necessary it's not necessary
it's not necessary there man don't don't
even get into all this spat you know
hurt feelings you bet money nobody told
you bet your house when your man you
know your man ain't have a jab like that
but yo
thank y'all for rocking with me i've
been rocking with you guys it's
fantastic tonight i'm sorry
i love it hello
um
but yo this this was
we we watched history so far this whole
year
and hopefully it culminates at the end
with uh uh crawford
versus my man spence man this this is
good this is how he he gave him the
belch man he respect them
he's gonna do it again he's making a
boatload of money he's making a boatload
of money man this is what's up man but
thank you all for coming out again it's
fantastic ill don't drink and drive
everybody should be at home right now
and relax and oh hold on suicide kings
and 2 super chat spiderman on pc mouse
morales 2 coming
bring it tomorrow yo yo tomorrow is the
is the microsoft show all right so yo i
can't really be talking about that but
go back to the playstation enjoy then
you know hey man
but thank you guys again i i truly
respect you guys thank you again you're
rocked all the way out with me catch
y'all guys tomorrow on iop at 1 p.m
eastern standard time
see y'all next week it's been fun it's
been a blast thank you guys
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
welcome to work
presents the featured event of the
evening
as tonight
[Music]
presented
[Music]
[Music]
ain't no competition in the ring
decipher cause i'm spitting financial
swing
cause i might go look like a rude
discussion and deflate your chest like a
fool production you'll be talking like
you want a new concussion center dude a
custom attitude adjustment
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that i deserve for another
knuckle sandwich i would serve having
tipping moving like a tire swerve out
here acting bad thank you michael
jackson even got his one and only homie
captain you a phony homie now you owe me
action have him sinking tony tony tony
braxton and they all want to talk for
attention but the fame only lasts for an
instant momma got hands so i'm ready for
the tension i'm a little red you can
dance
[Music]